so I understand
your rationale
saying that um movie studios are
concerned about losing money which means
that they do something that they think
is going to be both socio-politically
popular and they're rebooting and
remaking existing franchises because
that seems to be an easier way to go but
surely the type of turnout that we've
been seeing at the cinema especially
post pandemic right which is going to
have had a bit of an impact but more so
because movies don't seem that
compelling and if the director is
lambasting me for being too much of a
homophobe to go and watch a gay rom-com
that's that's definitely going to put me
off no matter my predilection around
that sort of a movie
surely studios are eventually going to
have to create things that people want
to actually watch or else they're going
to go broke like is there not hope in
the future that the market is going to
reform
these Production Studios into making
things that we actually want to see
yeah there absolutely is
um the thing you have to keep in mind is
that like all of this stuff has like a
three-year lead time
so like you're watching movies now that
are coming out in movie theaters they
were commissioned in like 2019.
because you know it takes a long time to
make a film obviously like you know
you've got a scripter you've got to cast
people you've got a director thing
you've got to shoot the thing uh then do
all your post-production then get it on
its slate then get it marketed so
um in a sense what you're seeing in
cinemas right now are ideas from like
three years ago and that's why we're
still getting [__] movies that that do
all this stuff because probably
Hollywood is now recognized the the
mistakes that they made or they're
starting to recognize it uh and so that
they're starting to make those changes
to their Productions but that's not
going to come out for a couple more
years you know it takes time and this is
why you you often hear from people
saying it's gonna get worse before it
gets better because it probably will you
know
um Warner Brothers is a great example of
that
they have been losing money for years on
their their DC movies and stuff
um they brought in a guy called Walter
Hamada who was wanting to take it in the
the super walk Direction where you were
gonna do away with Superman do away with
Batman they were going to get replaced
by Supergirl and Batgirl
um and it was going to be them and
Wonder Woman like it was going to be all
female
um that I think they race swapped a
couple of them as well you know all of
that walk stuff just distilled into one
perfect triumvira of nonsense
um
he's been fired he he he's gone now they
brought in a guy called David zaslov he
looked at all this stuff that was coming
up and he was like [__] no and cancel
the whole bunch of it
um canceled Batgirl when it was made it
was ready to go they spent 100 million
dollars on this thing and he's like no
it's so [__] it's not even gonna get
shown ever it's gonna interval nobody
can ever see it ever you know in case it
in the lead and drop it at the bottom of
the Atlantic exactly yeah I like bird it
insult the ground and stuff but that's
you know that was that change of
Direction because they could no longer
afford to indulge this nonsense because
they were running out of money they had
to bring in a guy who was hard-nosed a
businessman who just uh hopefully had an
eye for making good quality films and
it's happened to them it's gonna happen
to other Studios as well
it just takes time
lead time thing is so interesting and I
didn't think about it at all I also know
how long it takes to make video games
and that there is a maybe a concern
you're talking maybe seven years between
five and seven years to make a you know
a pretty good game
um I wonder whether computer games are
going to go that way as well I would
guess that the studios that make games
are a little bit more in touch with what
their core audience is after but you
know there was a news story part way
through last year saying that the new
GTA was going to feature lower rates of
violence and it was going to restrict
some of the things that you could do
which was going to be commenced with
more Progressive understandings of
social policy in the blah blah blah
they are going to get much more
immediate feedback from their fans
saying [__] no
than you can from a cinema I think yeah
it's like know your audience guys come
on you don't play a GTA game to be
politically correct you know I mean this
like uh yeah they've spent 20 years
allowing people to like shoot up entire
streets where the people run [__] over
with cars you know Murder prostitutes
whatever all the like
um whatever depraved stuff people can
come up with you could probably do it in
those games
um but that that was just part of the
anarchic fun of them and so to try and
suddenly develop a social conscience now
it's like no that's that's not why
yeah you can't you can't just you can't
suddenly Rebrand yourself as a
responsible company like you know
um restricting all this stuff but yeah I
think the reaction was pretty severe um
and I think with gaming
um I'm trying to think what I can equate
it to
um there was some there was like the the
Battlefield games you know first person
shooters and they tried to release one
called battlefield v a couple years ago
secure in World War II but it had uh
women fighting on the front lines with
uh cybernetic arms and stuff
um Asian men fighting in the you know in
the European Battlefield against Germans
uh just you know ridiculous but it's
like they tried they put that in the
trailer they showed that stuff and the
reaction was apocalyptic like fans
absolutely and lambasted the game is
ridiculous uh and it sold terribly as a
result you know so these things can
happen the backlash Works in some cases
what
so going beyond the interjection of race
and gender and sexuality
it does also seem like there's a kind of
a negative very pessimistic tenor to a
lot of movies as well that they don't
seem to put across a lot of genuine hope
what do you think is going on there is
that reflecting what our culture is like
now is that impacting on culture is it
just the fact that we're coming out of
the back end of I don't know a period
where people aren't feeling too happy
I I think so I think uh it ties into
this idea of
there's fewer just like heroic Heroes I
suppose
um and there's
there's not the kind of patriotic movies
that I think you used to get you know if
you if you look back to the 2000s
particularly you know
um for rather obvious reasons you know
America was fighting the war on terror
um and so there was a need and a desire
for heroism for for pro-american movies
for
um you know for just patriotism
um and
that doesn't really exist now
um
and again I don't know if it reflects a
kind of lack of confidence I don't know
if it reflects
um Hollywood's attitude to All Things
sort of American
um I I don't know if there's
weird associations there where it's like
they they feel like it's dangerous to be
be too you know Pro your own country I'm
not sure what the this the idea behind
it is but yeah I get what you're saying
in that uh there just doesn't seem to be
that optimistic view of like the whole
West the whole idea of Western culture I
suppose in movies but they'll repurpose
Fast and Furious 9 and Dumbledore
secrets of Albus or whatever it's called
to make it appropriate for a Chinese
audience
yeah it's interesting that isn't it when
money's involved
um yeah man I mean I've we've seen it in
ridiculous ways like they they tried to
Market black panther to the Chinese who
aren't very keen on the subject matter
and so they they took Chadwick boseman's
face from the poster and put the Black
Panther mask on him so you couldn't see
what was underneath you're okay to make
it no that they straight up did that
they erased him from his own movie to
try and make it more acceptable to
Chinese audiences and uh I thought the
days of Koto into China were done
because
it seemed for a while basically all
Disney movies were getting banned there
they just couldn't get a release and so
you kind of thought well okay maybe
they'll just think [__] it uh let if the
Chinese won't accept this anyway there's
no point trying to Pander to them let's
do something really crazy like be
pro-america
you know uh it's almost like we're an
American company and like our whole like
Walt Disney's entire outlook on life was
um like a fondness for all things
Americana you know he was a patriotic
guy he loved America
um be nice if they could live up to that
but nah they seem to have struck some
kind of deal I think now that um
Bob Iger is now back in charge they seem
to have smoothed things out with the
Chinese government and I've heard I
could be wrong but these are the rumors
that uh all the Marvel cast all the
Marvel actors are now being
um sent on little training programs to
teach them what's acceptable to say
about China so that they don't say
anything an offensive you know they
don't mention Taiwan or anything like
that so no one does a John Cena again
yeah exactly and it's just John at the
front you walk in and you've got Chris
Hemsworth and you've got Robert Downey
Jr and then stood at the front in a
teacher's outfit you've just got John
Cena don't end up like me John Cena
these entrance music that's what I'm
about I I boy that speech that he had to
give uh and fearful fair play for him
you know to be able to speak Mandarin
but uh to have to basically grovel uh
and and plead forgiveness because he
dared to suggest that Taiwan was a
country
um my God it was one of the most
humiliating things I think I've ever
seen and I just think imagine if that
happened back in the the 80s or 90s
you know what I mean like that would
never have happened but now this is the
world that we live in so
yeah I mean so I I it's it's hilarious
and I've spoken about it a ton and it is
embarrassing and cringe-worthy and
evidently just straight up capitalism in
its worst form
however
if there was the risk of the entire
Studio that you were with and all of
your cast members and all of the people
that you'd worked with and every single
person basically having 50 or 30 or
something of their revenue hanging on
whether or not you're prepared to say
something in Mandarin for 90 seconds the
pressure is absolutely astronomical I I
still think it's a super cringe-worthy
thing to do but the situation in which
you wake up that morning and re get the
message from your manager or the studio
saying hi mate you shouldn't have said
that about Taiwan we need you to fix
this there is a lot of pressure
I I think in that specific instance
because the movie was made with the idea
that it was going to get released in
China and so like it would have been
budgeted for that and so on okay there's
not much you can do it like if you've
screwed up you're gonna have to try and
fix it whatever way but uh you have to
ask yourself you know if you're actually
planning your movie in the first place
um what's your better strategy here is
it
you know we we
uh forego any kind of American
patriotism and we kind of like
incorporate weird uh sort of
pseudo-communist like messaging into our
movie to make it acceptable to China so
we get like an extra 20 revenue or
do we go super patriotic for America and
for like pro-western culture
and get like an extra 30 or 40 because
people actually love uh what we've done
over here I know which way I'd rather go
you know I mean like I know which would
be my preference but that's just me
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]